what's going on guys this is rob and at
c2e2 rosario dawson who played night
nurse in the marvel netflix shows came
out and said that punisher is returning
and john bernthal is coming back for the
role and we'll actually play the clip
here so you guys can see it i haven't
heard that announcement but i found out
yesterday that the punisher was
happening again so i feel like it's my
second chance because it was the only
one of the shows that i wasn't in and i
love john bernthal
so let's all make it happen collectively
guys
now recently rosario dawson came out
again and said that apparently some
random fan told her that was the case so
that uh i guess it's not actually
happening if i'm being honest i think it
is i think she leaked it and she wasn't
supposed to talk about it and that
disney basically raked her over the
coals so then she had to come out and
say well
some random fan told me it was true i
have a hard time believing that rosario
dawson just believed a random fan at
c2e2 and then came and got on stage in
front of thousands of people or hundreds
of people and was like hey guys john
bernthal is coming back as a punisher on
disney plus you know i have a hard time
believing that's the case so i'm gonna
kind of assume that it is happening and
here's the thing i have a few thoughts
about this whole thing i have a few
thoughts about the punisher on disney
plus i'm a little on the fence about it
and and really kind of worried about it
and here's the reason why when it came
to the punisher on netflix it was really
just kind of netflix given full license
in terms of how the punisher could be
brutal and gruesome and all the things
that we've come to expect and this is an
important thing the reason why is
because i'm a little fearful that if the
punisher comes or when the punisher
comes to disney plus that they're going
to tone it down or they're going to tone
it down and make it kind of like a pg
punisher and that doesn't work and we
know that from a variety of instances in
marvel comics when they've tried to make
it work those guys who are unfamiliar
the punisher exists in marvel comics in
two forms the first form is the main
marvel universe so the punisher's
appearance in like civil war and when he
first appeared in the spider-man comics
and welcomed back frank and different
things like that then there is the
punisher in the max imprint and the max
imprint was marvel's line of
adult-oriented comics i mean sex
violence all kinds of stuff right like
these were comics that were not meant
for kids and the punisher is every bit
as brutal there and some of the best
stories ever written about his character
are from marvel max right the punisher
max run that was originally done by
garth innis is landmark and the stuff of
legend punisher born the cell all those
different stories were in the max
imprint and they depict him as an
exceedingly brutal character and that's
something that has to be maintained and
the reason for that is best depicted and
in fact this was actually covered in an
article that i saw that was on amino app
so we'll link it down in the description
it was best covered when somebody did an
analysis of the rooftop scene from
daredevil season two between frank
castle and daredevil himself now i don't
know if you guys forgot that scene at
all it's one of the most iconic scenes i
don't know of anybody who could forget
that scene but it's an amazing scene
that actually highlights the stark
difference between frank castle and
someone like daredevil right in that
scene when the two of them are kind of
having this conversation back and forth
one of the greatest lines from just the
entirety of marvel in general of all the
tv shows and films they've ever made is
when frank is talking to matt murdock
and he says i think you're a half
measure right he's like you knocked him
down and they get back up i knock them
down and they stay down and that's the
thing right in this article one of the
things that they said is that the
punisher is a guy who puts it all on the
line because he's a man with nothing to
lose and when you're a man with nothing
to lose you can basically do anything
you want to and that's the nature of the
punisher the punisher is a guy who has
nothing to lose right because he lost
everything that mattered to him and so
now he'll do whatever it takes right
he's kind of the antithesis the
difference between someone like matt
murdock who's kind of a high road
defeatist he would rather lose and
maintain his morals than do whatever it
takes to win as opposed to someone like
the punisher who will do whatever it
takes to win and guys like the punisher
usually always come out on top it's not
something that you see too often when it
comes to films or tv shows the good guys
usually win but that's because on a
societal level we demand that be the
case we demand that the good guy win so
we fudge the numbers we cook the books
we sort of rearrange the pieces of the
puzzle to make them fit the way that we
want it to in order to fit our desire to
defy reality and ensure the good guy
comes out on top but it usually doesn't
work that way because the good guy goes
in expecting to lose he acquiesces right
the good guy goes in saying i'm not
going to do whatever it takes to win i
will do whatever i can to win so long as
i don't violate my moral compass and
because the bad guy doesn't have that
same moral compass and will do whatever
it takes to come out on top the good guy
basically goes in expecting to lose they
basically said i won't cross this line
and the bad guy says i will and they win
and that's basically how things work is
how the real world works and the
punisher is a great reflection of that
sort of difference between the high road
defeatist like daredevil and the winner
take all do whatever it takes person
like the punisher the tv show was a
perfect instance of this again that
rooftop scene where he referred to
daredevil as a half measure a guy who
knew that there are some people out
there that just can't be fixed there's
no way to like get them to see the error
of their ways they're not going to wake
up one morning and say oh my god what
have i been doing with my life i've been
committing crimes and stuff like that
right it's not one of those things where
the daredevil keeps locking them up and
on the fifth time they finally come to
their senses no no right like it's them
just doing what they want to do because
they know that at the end of the day the
daredevil is a toothless guy right he
will only go so far and so punisher is
not that guy punisher will just kill
them now another thing to know is the
mental state of the punisher that when
it comes to frank castle in the tv show
right in the netflix series one of the
things that was so great about his
character is you always knew he was
walking a knife set right you always
knew that just at a moment's notice he
could just fall off the deep end right
he could just fall off and just totally
lose it a really good example of this
didn't necessarily happen in the show
although the overall theme was felt in
the show but it was from garth ennis
punisher max right in a story called up
is down and black is white and it was
this absolute just amazing monologue
that frank castle has so in this
monologue he says there's this dream i
have from time to time and in this dream
i don't stop i kill all the soldiers and
the hitmen the extortioners and
racketeers the dark old [ __ ] who send
them all out to fight i hold the trigger
down until they're all gone but i don't
stop the innocents are watching just
like always the slack jawed thousands
gazing at the beast my family lies red
and shredded in the grass i face the
crowd and bring the weapon to my
shoulder if my world ends i tell them so
does yours the recoil starts and then i
wake up and it's just one of these great
moments right because that theme was
felt in the punisher show right in
daredevil season two and the punisher
seasons one and two it was it was such a
great idea to have because what it
showed is that one frank hassell
believes that happiness is beyond his
ability to attain that he lost that
which was most important to him he can
never get it back and he can never go
back to being the man that he was before
the second thing it illustrates is that
he doesn't simply just blame the death
of his family on some botched police
operation he blames it on society as a
whole he blames it on people because at
the end of the day people know
corruption happens people know that
there are criminals out there yet they
turn a blind eye they tilt their hats
down they walk forward they pretend they
don't see anything and that innocent
people are caught in the pathway of
individuals just personal
irresponsibility or lack of concern over
corruption and things that go wrong in
society and so he blames the average
person just as much as anything else
because his stance is you could do
something about this you just choose not
to because you're a coward and so
looking at society in that way he
harbors resentment for effectively
everybody right for every single person
out there and that kind of sentiment is
something that you would really lose
because the best way to demonstrate that
anger and that wrath and that pain is
the violence that frank castle ensues in
the fact that he throws his own
individual safety to the wind doesn't
quite care what happens to him right
this is shown in that diner fight in
daredevil season two right when karen
page is watching the whole thing go down
and he's caught up in just that super
violent fight he doesn't care how
injured he gets another really good
example of this is the fight he's in in
the prison now some of that was
contextual there was no real escape for
him in that prison hallway the doors
were locked and so on and so forth but
the fact that he just throws himself at
those guys takes his hits and just keeps
on going you can tell he doesn't really
care about himself he doesn't care about
his own individual safety his concern
about his life is limited to as long as
i'm alive i can kill other criminals but
like when the time comes when all
criminals are basically destroyed what
would happen with frank castle this was
answered in punisher the end when
basically humanity ends up engaging in a
nuclear war that's caused by politicians
and different things like that and that
he ends up finding i mean he ends up
succumbing to radiation sickness but
he's basically led to a bunker where the
last of humanity resides which is
essentially politicians and businessmen
and business women that are trying to
find a way to basically save embryonic
cells for humans so they can in turn
repopulate the earth with humanity frank
castle goes in there kills everybody i
mean like you know with the exception of
that bunker everybody else is dead they
literally play a recording where the
president of the united states went
crazy took everybody out and then offed
himself so basically this bunker right
the people here are all that's left of
humanity frank castle kills them all
destroys what's left of those embryonic
cells and basically causes humanity to
go extinct then he just goes out and
literally walks into a fire succumbs to
his radiation sickness and dies so frank
castle basically kills humanity he's the
reason why humanity goes extinct on
earth but that instance is where he's
just like humanity doesn't deserve to
live anymore humanity had its chance and
humanity did what humanity does best
which is screwing everything up and so
it's so interesting when you look at
that because in the show on netflix so
many of those themes of what really
makes the punisher who he is are
captured so incredibly well but if this
show is rolled over into disney plus and
we get a pg rating it's not going to do
the punisher justice it's not going to
feel like an actual punisher show it's
going to feel like captain america 3
civil war where it's more like a civil
disagreement that's what it's going to
feel like you're going to get a very
toned down frank castle a less violent
frank castle and you're not going to
feel those themes that frank is a guy
who doesn't really care about his own
life who does what he does because it's
really him just taking out vengeance on
the world he's not a batman character
where he's like my mommy and daddy got
shot and i want to make sure that nobody
else feels the pain of losing their
loved ones so i'm going to beat up
criminals in the middle of the night and
hand them over to the cuffs no there's
no greater reasoning here there's no
higher cause that the punisher is trying
to attain he literally just kills people
who commit crimes and that's it well he
doesn't see any criminal as anybody who
can be redeemed in any capacity
criminals die and that's the end of that
it's an absolutist viewpoint you won't
really feel that in the disney plush
show you would feel more like batman it
would feel more like well i mean the
punisher he gives them what amounts to
like a stern talking to right you know
like that's basically a slap on the
wrist and that's that's all you would
really see so i think that in order for
the show to really have that gritty
element to really have that hyper
violent element that concept that shows
that frank castle doesn't actually care
whether he lives or dies that frank
castle is not some high road defeatist
like daredevil that he's willing to do
whatever it takes to come out on top to
ensure that his goal is achieved which
is the death of those criminals over
there and any other criminals that exist
out there this show has to have what
would be a tv mature rating it has to be
a carryover from the netflix show in
terms of its feel and what you were
shown to the show on disney plus you can
certainly have the drama with a tv pg
rating right you can't have that you can
have those rooftop discussions between
frank castle and and daredevil but the
reality is without that hyper violent
element without the instance where all
those guys are hanging on meat hooks and
daredevil comes in and he finds one of
them who's still alive and he was like
who did this tell me who they are and
the guy says not they one it was one man
unless you have that then that rooftop
scene is lost that moment doesn't have
the same level of significance that it
does and the reason why is with moments
where all those guys are on meat hooks
or all those guys get shot to pieces
when that that irish mob is having that
meeting or whatever and you see frank
castle as a one-man army who will beg
borrow steal and kill in order to
achieve his goal
you lose the significance of the rooftop
scene you lose the significance of you
knock them down and they get back up i
knock them down and they stay down right
like that whole that whole meaning is
lost there so i think in order to really
feel frank you've got to have a mature
rating you've got to have what amounts
to an r-rated tv show but the question
is is that something they would put on
disney plus and to be honest with you
guys i think that's a hard no i think
that seeing like seeing the punisher on
disney plus is gonna be a pg-rated show
and i really hope it's not right i
really hope i'm wrong i 100 hope that
i'm wrong here and i really hope it's a
tv mature show i really really do but
with that being said let me know what
you guys think down in the comments
section thank you all for watching and i
will catch you all later
peace